what is the worst nanability in Hunter
Hunter I've got my opinions on this but
Nan mate Nan is just so subjective one
person's worst ability could be another
person's dream ability so we've had to
work really hard to find the abilities
that are not only objectively the bottom
of the barrel but are in fact the bottom
of the barrel on the bottom of the
barrel Tower in the world's worst Barrel
Factory the one infested with the
Cockroaches and such and you know I
think we're starting off pretty strong
with the one that gets you pregnant with
other people's problems yes that is a
real none ability and that is a
fantastic description of it this is
referring to hina's Nan exorcism which
are not so great abilities in general
but this is an order of magnitude worse
than most as Tina can remove those
peskin and curses but depending on how
strong said curse is Hina becomes
equally as bloated in what I would
describe as a pregnant Samana thus you
have quite literally become impregnated
with someone else's problem because
that's the really janky thing about
being a net Exorcist once you've taken
that curse away the original target has
no reason to help you it's your curse
now have fun with that I should also say
that the other side of the coin has an
equally as dirty embossed Queen
Elizabeth on it because Nan curses
aren't amazing abilities to have either
a lot of times nen curses are the most
costly abilities a great example would
be second Prince Camillus have not a
final condition for them to activate
their curse is to kill themselves and in
that case in that case alone I would
rather be pregnant the ability that
ikalgo has oh that's a good one and by
good I mean bad very bad all of a sudden
pregnancies looking pretty good again
Living Dead Dolls of course allows our
favorite marine life to insert himself
into the corpse of a deceased individual
and control them as far as manipulation
goes I can certainly think of less
morbid abilities that accomplish a
similar result but it's also an ability
that would be completely useless unless
you were an octopus or maybe not
completely but you'd have to like insert
yourself into something massive like an
elephant or a whale and I don't know if
that's appealing to anyone but not to me
no controlling an elephant might be
pretty fun they can run surprisingly
fast but I don't want to like put myself
into the elephant corpse there's a big
disconnect with this ability in me fun
facts though with calgo is an extremely
rare Chimera ant as he is one of the
very few who retains memories from both
his former human life and his former
animal life and from the latter ikalgo
carried over his dream of becoming a
kairoth of his
hirokutis imperator that one he wanted
to become that one which is better known
as an emperor squid I should have just
said Emperor squid but this is far from
the only morbid ability we have that
corpse disposal post-mortem nenability
so this is referring to zombie gun a
very recent ability used past tense by
Misha a member of the jiyu family and
what we see of it is a more powerful
version kind of like what a cowgirl does
you know taking control of a corpse and
then manipulating it to present the
illusion that said corpse is alive and
zombie girl then goes on to dispose of
the body never to be found again very
very useful for underworld operations
and that is our problem right there I
should not be using the word useful at
all in this video unless it's to say
this ability is not useful which I
didn't do but I guess I will say that if
you're in a position where zombie girl
is useful than that's a pretty gruesome
indictment of your life but maybe
there's a way to like hack the ability
for day-to-day use like say you finished
eating some chicken you throw what's
left in the bin and then you summon
zombie girl to dispose of both the
chicken and the rest of the garbage at
the same time I mean that doesn't
actually work because you have to kill
for zombie girl to activate and you also
need to be a member of the GU family
doesn't exist in reality so you know
what uh pretty not so great power bin
odds and inability I don't think I'm the
type of person to walk up to people I
don't know cut their hair and then eat
it in front of them this one was
definitely the most referenced worst in
an ability and I guess as a whole the
glob of people watching this video
really do not want this power weirdly
enough though I think it's the best of
the worst Powers we've encountered so
far because after consuming the hair
Bernard gains biological insight into a
Target that we may not even have medical
tests to detect if he was a doctor
instead of a serial killer then this
ability would be invaluable it would
make him a millionaire perhaps even tens
of millions maybe hundreds and some
people have said that it would also be
useful to like a detective or Lauren
enforcement but the issue is that
Bernard can't just eat any old hair off
the floor and analyze information
because the key restriction is that the
hair needs to be cut with and I quote
binult's favorite scissors so bringing
him into an established crime scene is
no good he would need to be there at the
time of the crime at which point his
ability may be less than useful anyway
because he would have seen with his eyes
who it was and he probably would have
killed murdered them himself let's let's
be real yeah remembering that bernalt is
almost absurdly powerful were he not
injured by biskey he could have killed
both gone and kilua the latter of which
being a superhuman then using assassin
and the former of which also being the
back to detective work though I'm not a
detective I've never worked in law
enforcement but I imagine it's probably
not a good idea to eat the evidence I
really don't know if a jury would take
that development too well well you see
your honor detective binault consumed
the evidence and his magical powers
deduced that the culprit was Clarence
[__] waffle all along and even in the
hunter hunter world with widespread
acceptance of magical powers you would
need to be extremely skeptical because
what if he's doing something like I
don't know lying still I think this is
definitely the best worst ability so far
and to celebrate his Bernal posing
fabulously in the hunter hunter mabugger
card game going full JoJo there the
surfboard ability that leol stole it
seems really situational seems that way
because it is it is very situational
however consider this the ability was
borrowed from an unseen character named
gratshan and the ability itself is
called imamura although in English it's
dubbed as surf sup it's an ability that
can only be used on a rainy day so
that's pretty bad if you live in places
like say Egypt Chile Antarctica other
dry places but when it's raining oh my
God quite literally because you
essentially gain the powers of Poseidon
or Neptune depending on if you're a
Greek purist or a Roman sympathizer
doesn't matter which one you pick you
are still a sea god I think it is a bit
confusing when watching or reading
Hunter Hunter because they all sort of
gives the illusion that the water is
conjured or even transmuted but that's
the reason for the Restriction it can
only be used on rainy days because it
can only be used to manipulate the rain
so it's how it directly correlates to
how heavy the rain is but even with a
light sprinkle it's pretty damn
formidable and one of my favorite
exchanges during the slail fight was
moral avoiding the whirlpool and saying
now it's my turn and then lael's just
like you don't get any turns no turns
for you all of the turns belong to me
lion man I don't know why I like it so
much but I do but I'm gonna go ahead and
say that this nanability is not only the
worst but is in fact one of the most
underrated in the entire series parallel
future I think I would go insane if I
had that ability the anxiety of knowing
the future I can't handle it that
comment right there coming allegedly
from Susan wijicki CEO of YouTube oh I
have a letter from her actually from
Susan let me get it go a nice special
letter from our commenter here Susan we
don't know if you can see it down the
bottom there there we go look at that
good to see you Susan unfortunately
we've gone from one of the most
underrated net abilities to one of the
most overrated now because parallel
future is extremely powerful but I don't
think that people quite consider the
long-term impact of it in the hands of
an average person I think this ability
could end up being much more of a curse
than a benefit just think about how long
you spend Doom scrolling on social media
because you've developed a habit of
always needing to be connected that
would 100 happen if you had the ability
to look into the future if you're bored
you'd always just be hopping in to fill
some time and then you'd be even more
bored because all you see is you 10
seconds into the future still being
bored it's a vicious cycle of boredom
but it could also take a much more
harmful turn into paranoia I mean if you
had a guaranteed window into the future
you'd evolve to a point where you'd feel
very naked and exposed whenever you are
not using that power so I'm gonna come
clean here I myself cannot see into the
future so as a result I'm pretty alright
with going with the flow but if I could
I'd probably probably become very
addicted and paranoid about checking
like say I'm about to cross the road oh
no quick let's just have a bit of a
parallel future just to check if
everything's going to happen safely and
I would probably be like that with
everything which sounds absurd and no it
wouldn't be like that straight from the
gecko but with something so powerful I
just feel like it's human nature to
develop an over-reliance on it and on a
certain stage you may even cease to live
in the present entirely just always
focused on the future until one day all
you see is black indicating that you are
going to die within the next 10 seconds
it just doesn't sound as appealing as
most known abilities I mean extremely
powerful yes but sort of be careful what
you wish for the girl from York knew who
has to kiss her Target I don't want to
have to kiss a bunch of strangers right
so this is instant lover used by Bez
which means kiss in French an especially
awkward post-pandemic power because
people are now less likely to let you
randomly kiss them even if you are some
sort of gorgeous 2D woman although
speaking of if you were anything less
than sex on legs of any gender then this
ability would be even harder to use
without being charged for sexual assault
with that said I would still prefer it
to pregnancy and inserting myself into a
corpse so it's definitely not the worst
hakaware only because I am bad at math
you know that's the funny thing you
don't need to be good at maths because
this ability it does all of the
mathematizing for you this delighting
little creature does all of the
calculations and works the Glorious
sorcery that is compound interest
meanwhile all you need to do is sit
there and wait for your opponent to go
bankrupt akaware itself is actually a
mahjong term for a player whose 0.4
below zero and thus immediately end the
game now knuckle does use it with his
unexpectedly amazing math skills and
he's at the point where he can see how
much Aura is invested and then calculate
exactly how long it will take for an
opponent to go bankrupt which is Handy
but you don't need to do that what you
really need to do is have a bit of a
thwack in the sack and that compound
interest carry you to victory so it's
not the worst ability in fact it's not a
bad ability in fact it's a really good
ability but a misunderstood ability Pike
do I need to explain more you don't but
I will because I am surprised that so
few people said this one I mean this is
a hot suit that just it makes my butt
clench in Phantom Pain Mike's ability is
called Deluge demore which makes it
sound more like a romantic twist than
what it actually is which in reality is
more akin to taking a big like really
big and very detailed dump in English
it's called love shower and it allows
Pike to rapidly excrete web from his
spider butt and honestly that it could
be useful the webs are really powerful
and I'm sure it would be handy for many
circumstances but I just That's funny
though I said but but I just don't want
to do that the reason why I really enjoy
Pike though is because we don't often
get to say this word but Pike's cause of
death was exsanguination aka the removal
of blood which also happened to karasu
and togashi's previous series you
Hakusho with that karasu also bearing a
weird resemblance to the one-piece
karasu which came along much later which
is something that I've only just picked
up on summer and speaking of none
ability to turn myself into jacket so
you've got the wrong series here but I
know that about 70 of you watching also
watch groundline review so you you know
what this guy's talking about this is
referring to the Joker joking to me a
devil fruit whereby the user transforms
into a jacket and then must be worn by
someone which is really interesting to
examine in the context of Hunter Hunter
because this really kind of useless
power would be shockingly difficult to
achieve with nen for all of the crazy
wacky crap the Nan can do body
manipulation is still extremely rare and
costly to pull off and the idea of
morphing your body into a jacket would
require a seriously powerful known
veteran like subhani except she
transforms into useful things like
motorcycles and planes as opposed to to
clothing actually you know it's probably
not even body manipulation it's more
like body transmutation or maybe even
body conjuration because you have to
turn into a substance be it metal or
fabric anyway it's crazy area and one
that we still don't quite know enough
about meanwhile there are also some nen
abilities that make this video due to
the fact that they would be dead weight
in reality such as kamagi's gungi skills
which won't really help because it's a
fictional game grollo skill Hunter was
also cited many times and would be
pretty rubbish in reality with no other
n users then you've also got impossible
conditions like Emperor time needing
Scarlet eyes or banolanov's battle
cantabla needing various bodily holes
like more than your standard amount of
holes it actually turns out that a
massive amount of abilities are just
completely dead weight with anyone but
their originator which makes stuff like
chichu's crossbow slightly more
appealing because many people cited this
as the worst nanability but hey at least
it can be used universally but look I
think we found out when a priority early
on in this video and we're going to give
the award for worst and ability to use
to wikalgo's Living Dead Dolls